[Musique]
descendez
l'Avenue ou le Tennessee est
[Musique]
Mississippi
Memphis est un club de musique
Elvis Presley un Johnny Cash
rural [
Musique]
OK
Adams visiteurs
[Musique]
Il y a 196 ans, les factures étaient tourmentées par
ce qu'ils appellent l'esprit le  les voisins
appellent la sorcière certaines personnes appellent le
démon
et la légende John Bell a été empoisonné par
l'esprit qui se fait appeler Kate
ces choses ont été vues à l'intérieur de la
grotte locale les gens croient que les orbes des esprits
même les fantômes peuvent parfois être entendus
parler
j'ai des amis qui sont partis  là-bas,
ils pouvaient sentir la présence de la
sorcière
et quand je suis descendu, j'ai vu un fantôme
derrière le poêle,
je suis convaincu que quelque chose de très très grave
était dans cette maison,
ce que c'était, nous ne savons vraiment pas. On
a demandé à Spirit
où es-tu venu  de
et il a dit que je suis un esprit et j'ai
été perturbé J'existe depuis des
millions d'années,
cela devait être quelque chose de très puissant pour
faire ce qu'il a fait, mais cela n'a jamais
conduit à ce que c'était réellement
ils n'ont pas fait  comprendre pourquoi cela venait
après notre famille
et quand on lui a demandé pourquoi cela
venait après la famille Bell ou après que
John et l'esprit aient dit qu'il avait juste besoin
de tuer des gens dans la région continuent de
prétendre voir des observations de la sorcière Bell
qu'ils prétendent  l'entendre au milieu de
la nuit, ils entendent le bruit des choses
dans la maison ou peut-être dans les bois et
ils attribueront cela à la
sorcière Bell mais c'est censé être un
esprit éternel éternel
et euh vous savez que la plupart des gens le regardent
comme  une sorte de souhait juste autour du
balai mais ce n'est pas comme ça que j'ai jamais
décrit par les cloches ils
le décrivent toujours comme une voix
ou une entité et ils prétendent qu'ils pourraient
voir de temps en temps certains qu'il
se présente comme un animal ou un
être humain  maintenant, les voisins ont toujours entendu les
voix mais beaucoup d'entre eux ont dit qu'ils
ne voyaient pas la forme qui
se manifestait parfois selon la légende et bien vous
avez vos croyants et vous avez vos
non-croyants et avec cela vient l'
étendue de dans les deux domaines vous en avez
qui sont très hardcore je ne crois pas
aux fantômes je n'admettrai jamais qu'il
y a une sorcière cloche et puis vous avez
les gens qui croient vraiment qu'elle a
existé et qu'elle a tourmenté cette
famille Bell pendant des années et qu'elle continue
de tourmenter les gens dans  Le comté de Robertson alors
qu'ils visitent Adams soi-disant l'un des
fils de euh Brit de John Bell a servi
avec Andrew Jackson
Andrew Jackson est revenu et a eu une
confrontation avec cette entité Andrew
Jackson a eu une rencontre agréable avec elle
mais il a abusé des gens avec qui il était
et  il a été cité comme disant qu'il
préférerait affronter l'ensemble de l'
armée britannique plutôt que d'affronter à nouveau la sorcière Bell,
eh bien maintenant, cela apparaissait comme plusieurs
choses différentes dans l'histoire, c'était
comme une dinde un loup une petite fille dans
une balançoire
que lorsque Betsy a essayé de lui parler, elle
a disparu
étrangère
[Musique] La
mort de Bell
a été attribuée à un esprit et c'est la
seule personne que je connaisse dans l'histoire des
États-Unis dont la mort a été attribuée
à un esprit
[Musique]
étrangère
[Applaudissements]
maison
à  1817 selon la légende, les cloches
ont commencé à ressentir le phénomène qu'elles appellent
l'esprit les voisins l'ont appelé une
sorcière et cela a commencé à tourmenter la famille
en particulier John Bell et sa plus jeune
fille Betsy John Bell avaient beaucoup de
problèmes de santé et ils ont blâmé cela sur
le  esprit, il a perdu ses chaussures parfois,
ils s'envolent littéralement de ses pieds et
ils devraient le récupérer Betsy a été
giflée, ses couvertures ont été enlevées à
plusieurs reprises, ses cheveux étaient attachés et
encochés autour du montant du lit Betsy semblait
être ciblée plus que l'autre
enfants et aurait des expériences
pendant la nuit d'être giflé être
rapiécé ses cheveux déchirés elle
crierait au milieu de la nuit
et la famille veillerait sur elle quand
les visiteurs viendraient passer la nuit
pour voir si ces histoires étaient réellement
vraies  eux aussi expérimentaient cela John ne
pouvait parfois pas parler c'était comme s'il
avait un bâton Crossways de sa bouche et
ensuite il irait mieux cela a duré
environ deux ou trois ans jusqu'à ce que
finalement
le 19 décembre 1820 John Bill
devienne extrêmement  malade
le médecin a été appelé
et il a été déterminé qu'il avait été
empoisonné ils commençaient à se demander
qui avait fait cela est-ce que quelqu'un dans la famille
a empoisonné John Bell euh est-ce que Betsy a fait ça est-ce que
le voisin a fait ça et tout d'un
coup ils ont entendu la voix qui  ils ont
entendu si souvent dans la maison
et l'esprit comme ils l'appelaient a dit que j'ai
tué le vieux John j'ai réparé son médicament
hier soir lui en ai donné une grosse dose
et il ne se lèvera jamais de ce lit
et John Bell est mort
je  Je suis arrivé à la conclusion que
quelque chose s'est définitivement passé J'ai
vu une lettre manuscrite de
1820 l'année de la mort de John
J'ai deux garçons qui rentrent chez eux chez leur
mère lors de leur voyage pour voir l'ange à
la maison Bell et ils ont pu  arriver
à la maison et la première nuit et
ils ont dit que rien ne s'était passé et la
deuxième nuit c'est arrivé et a dit maman
ce n'est pas un ange C'est le diable et
cela fait partie de la légende qui
continue à travers les années la
famille Bell est toujours ici à Robertson  Le comté
et il a une lignée qui existe jusqu'à
deux aujourd'hui et à cause de cela, l'histoire ne
cesse de passer de génération en
génération et est maintenue en vie
étrangère obscure
[Musique]
et puis j'ai entendu à la fin de cette salle que
la double porte a claqué les deux portes
et l'un d'eux s'est verrouillé alors ils ont dû
être déverrouillés et ils ont dû les
claquer, puis il y a eu des pas dans
le couloir qui se
sont arrêtés à ma porte et les cheveux sur mon
cou se sont levés et je n'étais pas
superstitieux je pensais que quelqu'un était
dans la maison
vous savez, je pensais que nous avions un intrus
et j'avais vraiment peur que Brian soit
probablement le plus effrayé que j'aie jamais eu,
alors je suis descendu, je suis allé dans notre
armoire à fusils et j'ai trouvé un 45 je l'ai chargé
dans la chambre et j'avais  il a
armé j'allais tirer sur quelqu'un
parce que je suis allé de pièce en pièce dans le
style de l'équipe SWAT et il m'a fallu environ une demi-
heure pour traverser toute la maison
parce qu'il y a deux escaliers et je
suis retourné et j'ai forgé et regardé
partout dans cette maison  il
n'y avait personne là-bas et j'ai dormi avec le
pistolet de verrouillage de la porte près du lit ma lumière sur
l'étranger
[Musique]
étranger [Musique
] [
Musique]
[Musique]
des histoires
ont commencé dans des grottes des
voix orbes à peu près tout ce que vous pouvez
nommer ont été soi-disant entendus et  il y a
quelques années au cours des 15 ou 20 dernières années,
quelqu'un a capturé une photo à l'extérieur de
l'embouchure d'une grotte ici et cela semblait être
une femme vêtue d'une robe blanche
apparue dans le film mais ce n'était pas sur
la photo quand ils ont pris  it
Nancy Bell et les enfants de la cloche
jouaient souvent dans la grotte qui se trouvait sur leur
ferme, ils prétendaient parfois avoir eu
quelque chose qui les poursuivait
et donc l'histoire d'un poisson géant juste
en dessous de la grotte pour remuer l'eau
et amener les enfants Bell à  soyez
très alarmé euh lors d'un voyage de la
rivière et de la grotte un jour, Betsy a
vu une petite fille pendue à l'arbre
et elle a parlé à Betsy et lui a dit
qu'elle ne devrait pas épouser son petit ami
Joshua Gardner, donc les grottes sont si importantes
pour le  légende et l'histoire de la
sorcière Bell dans le comté de Robeson J'enseignais un
cours d'histoire locale pour le Volunteer State
Community College
et le gars qui possédait la grotte, il
m'a demandé si j'étais déjà allé dans la grotte que
je n'avais pas et nous descendons  à la grotte
et nous reculons d'environ 250 pieds et je me suis
levé sur ce rebord avec ce monsieur pour
voir des dessins indiens ou quoi que ce soit et
les lumières s'éteignent et il est 10 ou 11
heures du soir et j'ai 10 ou 11
histoire  étudiants là-dedans alors nous sortons
de la grotte à tâtons et nous
arrivons à l'entrée de la grotte les
lumières se rallument
maintenant mon fils qui avait disons 79 ans alors disons
environ six ou sept ans je ne le laisserais pas
partir alors je  l'a fait rester avec la dame
à l'étage alors j'ai supposé qu'il avait
fait quelque chose avec la lumière il a dit
qu'elle n'avait pas bougé
[Musique] [
Musique]
le message familial
j'allais essayer de documenter où
les gens vivaient à l'époque  une grande partie
est
détruite j'essayais de trouver une
personne la tombe
son nom était Frank miles dans l'histoire
il joue un rôle en tant que voisin
et lui et John Bell Jr étaient
des amis proches j'ai parcouru la
campagne en essayant de trouver la tombe
[Musique]
tu ne pouvais pas le faire un matin vers
trois heures c'était en juillet je me suis réveillé j'avais
fait un rêve
et j'ai rêvé d'un petit bosquet d'
arbres
et je ne pouvais pas m'en débarrasser
juste je n'arrêtais pas d'y revenir
et vers le milieu de la matinée, je
pensais savoir où c'était
alors j'étais je suis allé dans cet endroit et il a
grandi avec Poison Ivy et
le chèvrefeuille, alors j'ai coupé toute la végétation
et gratter la saleté  hors de lui et j'avais
sur le gant et donc je l'ai frotté
et il a dit Frank R miles
Je l'ai doucement remis en place, je l'ai recouvert
et je suis parti je pensais que
ce n'était pas normal à ce moment-là
je pensais que vous saviez certaines choses  sont
mieux laissés seuls alors laissez-le tranquille
alors j'ai arrêté ma quête de localiser
où tous les autres ont été enterrés
juste je rentrais à la maison un soir et moi
et mes enfants et il y avait ça je ne
sais pas ce que c'était je ne peux pas  vous dire que ce
n'était pas un chat ce n'était pas une panthère ce
n'était pas un chien mais je conduisais et cet
animal est venu vers ma voiture et il était
noir pur et avait les yeux rouges c'est tout ce que je
peux dire vous ne savez pas  ce que c'était, je n'avais
jamais rien vu de tel auparavant et
il est venu vers moi, puis
s'est envolé et je n'ai jamais rien vu,
notre téléphone a sonné et c'était ma grand-mère
qui était vraiment bouleversée et elle a parlé
à mon père et  elle voulait qu'il
descende dès que possible nous sommes entrés dans
la maison et je me souviens que grand-mère
tenait toujours le téléphone et voyant à quel point
elle avait peur, elle a dit bien j'étais à
l'étage en train de faire une sieste et j'ai entendu ce
crash ce bruit fort et je suis
descendu  puis je suis entré dans la
cuisine et j'ai regardé par terre et
toute ma Chine était sur le sol de la cuisine
et la partie étrange à ce sujet était qu'il y avait un
Butler's Pantry entre la cuisine et
la salle à manger qui avait le
vaisselier intégré dans le mur avec
verrouiller les portes et les portes se sont ouvertes
et toute la Chine, chaque pièce
est sortie et s'est écrasée sur le sol non pas dans
le garde-manger du majordome mais dans la cuisine
et je me souviens juste de l'avoir vu se répandre
uniformément comme s'il venait d'être jeté
sur le sol
et non  une pièce était cassée et c'était et
c'était de la porcelaine tendre, donc je n'ai
aucune explication sur la façon dont cela s'est produit ou
pourquoi cela s'est produit, mais cela
n'a encore été expliqué par personne aujourd'hui
[Musique]
trouvera la sorcière Bell
dans les derniers chapitres du livre de Pat fitzhugh,
il parle de sa visite au
cimetière où
la famille a été enterrée et il parle
d'avoir ce sentiment d'une présence
là-bas au cimetière
il est  pas le seul il y a aussi des
enfants qui étaient allés là-bas et avaient
trouvé la pierre tombale de John Bell et
ils ramenaient le dangong
dans leur voiture et ils ont eu un
accident sur la route principale et ils sont
morts dans cet accident
encore une fois, l'histoire est que c'était la sorcière qui
était euh qui les a poursuivis
[Music]
American
c'est
[Music]
environ trois ans avant d'écrire le
livre
[Music]
dans la bannière de Nashville, il a écrit une
lettre qui  quiconque savait quoi que ce soit
au sujet de la famille Bell ou de la
sorcière Bell pour lui écrire des lettres et
des témoignages et il a parcouru le décompte de
toute
la campagne à Montgomery Robertson
et Adams dans toute cette région et a obtenu
beaucoup d'informations et de témoignages sur
les gens qui avaient entendu parler de la légende
ou connaissaient même les cloches l'
histoire qu'Ingram
raconte est qu'il a obtenu ceci, il a obtenu une copie du
journal qui a été écrit par Richard
Bell qui était le frère cadet d'Elizabeth Bell
au moment où cet événement avait  s'est produit
à Adams Tennessee Richard avait environ
six à sept ans
Richard puis 20 ans plus tard s'assied
et décide qu'il a raison il veut écrire un
journal
alors il écrit un journal et il l'a intitulé les
problèmes de ma famille
il donne son journal à son fils
son fils  puis environ 20 ans plus tard, apporte
ce journal
à
Marvin Ingram avec la stipulation qu'ils ne
pouvaient rien faire avec le journal
jusqu'à ce que toute la famille soit décédée toute la
famille de première génération soit décédée
la plus proche de la légende est le livre d'Ann Ingram
parce qu'il a interviewé des gens
à l'intérieur  la même époque qui était liée à
des personnes qui vivaient à l'époque où
la véritable légende a eu lieu,
beaucoup de gens considèrent vraiment
le premier livre d'Ingram, une sorte de
cloche, quelle Bible si vous voulez et je ne
sais pas pourquoi  Je sais que le livre d'Ingram est plus ancien, c'est
peut-être pourquoi Ingram était un très
bon écrivain, il était euh
éditeur de journaux et il écrivait dans le
style de son époque qui était les années 1890
parfois un peu de préjugés mais en
général c'est un très bon écrivain d'accord et
le  le livre est essentiellement rempli d'histoires
qui sont arrivées à la famille Bell selon lesquelles
ils ont commencé à entendre des bruits étranges et
ils ont commencé à voir des animaux étranges et
John Bell lui tirerait dessus et rien ne se
passerait là où ils s'enfuiraient
et il parle de John Bell plus tard
être tué  par le tube de la sorcière
est
[Musique]
des gens comme la famille Bell qui
étaient mes agriculteurs ils ont commencé
à s'installer dans cette région à cause de la
terre et de la fertilisation de la terre
nous sommes presque certains qu'ils cultivaient du
tabac il y avait une église qui  a été
établi en Caroline du Nord et il a
déménagé ici et principalement toutes les personnes
qui étaient dans cette église sont venues ici avec
l'église et John Bell était membre de l'
église baptiste de la rivière Rouge et il a été
excommunié, ce que je ne savais pas que le
baptiste avait fait mais il  était et il a été
expulsé de l'église pour un terme appelé
usury
TV
[Music]
ils étaient une famille importante en
Caroline du Nord quand ils ont emménagé ici
Je me suis souvent demandé pourquoi Cher John Bell, je
pense à l'âge de 56 ans si vous étiez
réussi là-bas et avait une
ferme ou une plantation en activité, pourquoi voudriez-vous partir
et emménager ici et recommencer à zéro
et il y a plusieurs histoires sur
ce qu'il a fait ou ce dont il a été accusé, c'est que
certains disent que c'était pour la vente d'un cheval
vendre de  terre fils d'un esclave ou quelque chose
comme ça, il l'a acheté à la famille des chauves-souris
et
Kate a senti qu'elle avait été trompée lors de l'
achat
Kate s'est sentie trompée par les cloches et qu'elle
a joué un rôle dans l'
expérience réelle de la sorcière cloche la
sorcière cloche en fait  utilise une voix que
tous les fantômes ne font pas
et elle se réfère à elle-même comme Kate et donc
cela vous ramène aux chauves-souris Kate et
nous ne sommes pas vraiment certains si Kate
Batts était la sorcière ou non vous savez que
vous savez qu'elle est la sorcière dit que  elle
était et fondamentalement que vous savez que ce
livre ici a été écrit par
Ingram et mais nous ne savons pas s'il
a déjà interviewé l'un des membres de la famille des chauves-souris
ou quoi que ce soit, le fantôme pourrait être Kate,
cela pourrait être Kate parce que c'est
la personne qui avait une
relation antagoniste avec John Bell, beaucoup de
gens pensent que c'est Kate parce que
le fantôme utiliserait la voix et
chaque fois qu'elle parlerait, elle se
désignerait comme Kate
bien que rien n'indique
que cela se soit produit en fait  les
fois où ils disent que Kate Bats était
la sorcière, le seul problème est que Kate Batts
était en vie à l'époque,
il est donc peu probable qu'elle ait
quelque chose à voir avec cela et ils ont aussi l'
autre chose que j'ai trouvée dans la recherche, c'est qu'elle
n'a pas vraiment  garder rancune de toute façon,
c'est une bonne question de savoir
comment Kate s'intègre dans tout cela puisque,
comme vous l'avez souligné, elle n'était pas morte lorsque
ces manifestations ont commencé à se produire, il
n'y a aucune preuve
qu'elle l'ait maudit qu'elle se sentait
trompée par lui, c'était au mieux  un
parent éloigné de la sienne,
donc je pense que c'est juste euh probablement
assez typique de la façon dont les légendes
se développent à l'époque, je pense que la superstition a
probablement joué un rôle très important, c'est
que dans les premières escortes d'hommes ou
escapades d'hommes, c'est que si vous ne pouvez pas
expliquez-le, cela doit être quelque chose que nous avons
fait pour contrarier Dieu, donc nous ne
le ferons plus si nous pouvons découvrir ce que
nous n'avons pas fait pour commencer,
donc c'est ainsi qu'ils expliquent que de nombreuses
actions étaient  à travers la superstition
étrangère
[Musique]
et pour la pièce c'est merveilleux nous avons
des artistes locaux là-bas nous avons beaucoup de
talents dans ce quartier beaucoup de
talent j'entends en 2006 il y avait environ un
millier de spectateurs à cette pièce
qui se déroule sur deux  ou trois week-ends de
suite et l'année dernière en 2012, il y avait
600 personnes qui ont visité, donc c'est vraiment augmenté,
ils ont changé l'histoire d'année en
année, ils ont différents personnages,
différents membres de la distribution et ils
essaieront de se concentrer sur différents aspects de  la
légende
et implique généralement au moins une partie de
la famille du projet de loi et parfois ils
auront une famille de chauves-souris liée aux chauves-souris dans
la pièce, mais c'est tellement bon
comme peut-être à New York, ils disent que vous
savez que l'endroit n'est pas meilleur
que notre  placez ici bien la curiosité
Les chercheurs viendront et ils feront
l'expérience de la cloche qui, en allant dans
l'esprit du jeu et chaque fois qu'ils vont
là-bas à Adams et regardent la pièce, il
leur arrivera parfois des choses qu'ils attribueront à la
sorcière cloche et  c'est pourquoi ils viennent souvent ici
parce que les gens sont fascinés par cette
histoire et le fait qu'elle ait
traversé les années et qu'elle ait duré aussi longtemps,
c'est juste fascinant pour les gens
et quand ils viennent et ils le font
faire l'expérience de la pièce, puis peut-être visiter
certains des sites sur lesquels il pourrait
leur arriver des choses qu'ils pourraient
penser que cela vient du paranormal et si
c'est le paranormal qui doit dire
Adams
[Music]
quand je suis venu en tant qu'étranger, j'étais un
non-  croyant, ce sont de petits
orbes vaporeux qui peuvent être vus, ils ne pouvaient pas
le voir en tant que personne, ils ont juste pu voir
un peu de mouvement et un peu de lumière, mais
je ne suis allé dans la grotte qu'une seule fois cette
nuit-là où les lumières se sont éteintes et
y'a cette dame qui est venue et elle
allait faire une séance
je n'ai pas envie d'y retourner et
oui la vérité je suis croyante on ne les a pas
vu mais on nous a dit par deux
personnes différentes
une qui était là haut euh
qui  n'était jamais venu ici auparavant et a dit
bien j'ai vu ce petit nuage aller du
cimetière au deuxième étage de
votre maison et nous avons également rencontré un autre
homme qui a grandi sur cette route quand il était enfant
et a dit qu'il n'avait jamais eu aussi peur dans son
la vie et j'ai vu la même chose
Montana
[Musique]
comme beaucoup de légendes et d'histoires de fantômes, elles
ont tendance à se transformer avec le temps,
surtout si les gens ont une motivation
et je ne vais pas en parler, je
ne vais pas faire d'allégations  mais il y
a de l'argent à gagner ici Marvin
Ingram a commencé un journal à Springfield
Tennessee, puis a déplacé ce journal
pour se rendre à Clarksville et les deux ont
dirigé le journal Thomas était le
journaliste et Ingram était le promoteur euh dans lequel
ils étaient entrés à ce moment-là  une sorte
de groupe Liars et le tout
était celui qui pouvait raconter l'
histoire la plus fantastique
bien, vous ne pouvez jamais ignorer les menteurs qui
mentent pour de nombreuses raisons et et certaines
personnes aiment l'attention certaines personnes veulent
croire
donc il y a toujours ça quand Marvin
Ingram  a écrit son livre au dos
de son livre, il a une liste de toutes les
personnes à qui il a parlé et interviewé pour
ce livre, vous devez retourner où
savons-nous même l'histoire que nous connaissons
de l'histoire d'Ingram à qui
il a parlé  personne n'ayant jamais été
impliqué directement avec les sorcières de Bell
il n'a parlé qu'à des personnes qui connaissaient des personnes
impliquées à mon avis cela n'aurait pu
être rien à mon avis cette
histoire aurait pu être totalement inventée il
n'a jamais parlé avec Elizabeth il n'a jamais
parlé avec  aucun membre de la famille et n'a
même jamais parlé avec le garçon ou Richard
Bell qui a écrit The Diary, ils ont refusé de se
séparer du journal jusqu'à ce que Betsy soit morte
et je me suis dit que c'était vraiment
génial parce que maintenant avec Betsy hors de la
photo et ils donnent le  journal qu'elle
n'est pas là pour interviewer pour vérifier ne pas
vérifier,
mais encore une fois, nous revenons à cela en supposant que
le journal a même existé, personne n'a même
vu les journaux, il n'y a aucune raison de
croire qu'Ingram n'aurait pas pu
tout inventer à part le fait que
ces personnes l'ont fait  exister la famille des arcs
existait est rapporté par Marvin Ingram
qu'Andrew Jackson a visité le site
maintenant qu'Andrew Jackson a visité après qu'il venait de
faire la Nouvelle-Orléans vous savez
Conquest là-bas, il a vaincu les
Britanniques à la Nouvelle-Orléans eh bien,
l'histoire de son entrée  la ville et
son chariot ne bougeaient pas et ainsi de suite
chaque fois que cela se
produisait, je veux dire qu'il était président, les gens
savaient où il était et il n'était pas là,
tout ce que cet homme aurait fait aurait
été écrit en détail d'accord,
j'ai  a fouillé ses journaux que
tout le monde a recherché comme
journaux, il n'y a absolument aucune mention
dans ses journaux d'
avoir jamais été à Adams Tennessee maintenant
sans prêt n'a pas eu
affronté la sorcière
je veux dire la façon dont cette légende s'est développée
elle a un peu  de tout ce que vous
savez qu'ils ont jeté dans des trucs de Poltergeist
qu'ils ont jeté dans des trucs de sorcières des
trucs de fantômes mauvaise sorcière Bonne sorcière il y a de la
religion jetée vous savez donc
c'est un bon moyen de faire
croire aux gens que vous savez mettre quelque chose là-dedans
qu'ils peuvent comprendre  et ils pourraient
ignorer le reste, mais ils croiront la
légende si elle a quelque chose qui leur parle
de la part de la famille
et des amis quand ils sont plus jeunes, mais
quand ils entrent dans le système scolaire,
cela sera parfois intégré dans
leur programme, ce que je ferais, c'est que
j'écrirai quelque chose sur un morceau de
papier
comme si ce n'était pas tel qu'il est ou quelque chose comme
ceci et la règle du jeu était
que la première personne dans cette rangée de classe
le lisait
et essayait de le mémoriser, puis j'ai pris
le morceau de papier et ensuite les règles du
jeu sont que vous vous retournez et que vous dites
à la personne derrière vous  exactement ce que vous avez
lu et qui a fait le tour de
la pièce jusqu'à la dernière personne
maintenant que le travail de cette dernière personne était de
monter et de monter sur le tableau exactement
ce qu'ils ont entendu, il n'a jamais commencé à
le diffuser de la même manière, donc j'ai
dit d'accord  maintenant nous avons établi les
règles pour raconter les histoires de Bell Witch. Les
images bien trouvées sont une technique bien connue
dans la fiction, elles sont utilisées dans la
littérature, elles sont beaucoup utilisées dans la science-fiction.
Film de journal de photos reliques quoi que ce soit qui dépeint
quelque chose qui est censé s'être produit, nous
connaissons tous le projet Blair Witch,
vous savez qu'ils ont trouvé ces vidéos de
ce qui s'est passé dans les bois,
nous savons que le projet Blair Witch est une
fiction,
mais ce que nous avons ici est le journal  est une
sorte de séquence trouvée, bien sûr, ils
n'avaient pas de vidéos à l'époque, nous avons donc
Ingram qui aurait cette source
qui n'est même pas si bonne mais c'est
un autre sujet
mais nous
contrairement au projet Blair Witch, il
n'a même pas  avoir le journal
étranger
[Musique]
ces
certificats Casey Tennessee
[Musique]
qui parfois est ouvert au public
et parfois non et parfois
autour d'Halloween, ils avaient l'habitude de dire qu'ils
feraient venir des gens et
ils euh  il se passait des choses,
vous savez, pour exciter les gens, alors une fois,
Beau était là, il était le prince du
propriétaire et il était là en train de prendre des
photos dans la grotte et il y a
cette dame qui est venue et elle allait
faire une séance avec un  quelques
photographes et tout et elle a vu
un arc en arrière-plan mais elle n'a pas
vu que c'était une personne qu'elle pensait que c'était
une cloche qui est entrée là pendant qu'ils
étaient là-bas
le bateau s'est reculé et a ri et est parti
parce qu'il savait que  il ne voulait pas
lui dire que c'était juste lui il ne
voulait pas faire éclater ta bulle une nuit je
restais avec ma grand-mère j'étais
très jeune de quatre ans tout au plus
et dans mon esprit
je me suis réveillé et j'avais juste l'impression d'avoir  descendre
au milieu de la nuit et quand je
suis descendu j'ai vu un fantôme derrière le
poêle
et même en tant que jeune enfant
je ne pensais pas que c'était un fantôme ça
n'avait même pas de sens pour moi je pensais
bien c'est  le garçon d'en face il s'est
faufilé dans la maison et il essaie de
me faire peur alors j'ai commencé à pleurer et j'ai couru
chercher ma grand-mère et elle est descendue
et bien sûr le fantôme n'était plus là
et je me souviens avoir ma tête sur ses genoux
pleurer et elle m'a calmé et
m'a dit que ce n'était qu'un cauchemar
et puis la façon dont je m'en souviens nous sommes
remontés et je me suis couché et je
n'ai pas pu m'empêcher de continuer à y penser
et je suis redescendu et c'était là
encore
maintenant pourquoi est-ce arrivé,
je pense que c'était un cauchemar peut-être un
rêve lucide de somnambulisme
mais ma grand-mère et moi
en parlions au fil des ans et je dirais
souviens-toi quand j'ai vu le fantôme et elle a
dit à Karen que ce n'était qu'un cauchemar
mais dans mon  l'esprit et aujourd'hui même aujourd'hui
c'était tellement réel
[Music]
euh et c'est pourquoi les gens croient en
ces choses
[Music]
quand vous venez à Adams, il y a beaucoup à
voir et à faire pour une petite ville
étrangère
[Music]
country amusant et
ils '  re de bons endroits pour manger, il y a le
barbecue Adams Station qui propose un excellent
barbecue et une cuisine maison et le
restaurant Mosses propose d'excellents steaks et hamburgers
et
ils étaient
autrefois la cafétéria de l'école.
il y a eu quelques petits
incidents ici Knox et tu
sais des trucs comme ça on a un petit
truc là-haut on colle nos billets
et on vole à travers la pièce
et personne n'était approché mais tu sais on
lui a juste dit tu sais d'accord vas-t'en
nous sommes occupés, nous n'avons pas le temps de manger avec
vous, alors oui, puis Red River Canoe est
un peu plus loin sur la route sur l'
autoroute 41 et cela offre une
expérience de camping et de canoë et ils ont
beaucoup de festivals tout au long de l'année mais
le  Les terrains de l'école Bell organisent également de nombreux
festivals toute l'année, nous avons le
spectacle des batteurs en juillet et cela
dure depuis environ 43 ans maintenant chaque
année et ils ont
des messieurs qui ont une
batteuse à blé à l'ancienne et une scierie
un atelier de forgeron et  d'autres
tracteurs antiques qui
exécutent réellement le métier là-bas, ils ont également
des tractions de tracteurs et d'autres activités, mais
c'est bien de voir comment ces
artisans fonctionnent, vous savez à l'époque,
nous avons également le concours Bell Witch Bluegrass
en septembre
[Musique]
danse carrée et musique bluegrass  et
cueillir et sourire partout sur le
terrain et nous terminons l'année avec le
jeu d'esprit en octobre pendant Halloween
qui raconte l'histoire de la famille Bell
et de la sorcière Bell
c'est une attraction touristique très fréquentée
et j'ai vendu des billets à des gens d'
Australie
Suède  L'Allemagne l'Ukraine et ils sont venus
et comment ils en ont entendu parler Je ne
savais pas que je savais que c'était un
phénomène local peut-être même un national mais un
international Je n'avais aucune idée que
la légende est très populaire elle existe
depuis 196 ans et les gens viennent
de  des milliers de kilomètres volent même d'
outre-mer pour en savoir plus sur les cloches et le
comté de Robertson et Adams, nous avons la
grotte de la sorcière des cloches et nous avons l'ancienne
terre agricole de John Bell senior et nous avons
un cimetière de cloches et une ancienne école de Bell que
nous allons visiter  le musée Bell Willett
de la ville d'Adams, nous allons
visiter la cabine Bell qui appartient
au musée lui-même au moins une partie de la
Bell House d'origine,
le bâtiment derrière moi est la dernière
structure debout de la
ferme Bale d'origine. c'était une cabine qui  certaines
datent d'être construites vers 1820 et
c'était l'époque de The Haunting qui se
déroulait et cette cabane a été déplacée ici
sur le terrain de l'école Bell au
début des années 1980 et cette cabane a été essentiellement
utilisée par des métayers jusqu'aux années 1970
donc il  a toute une histoire en soi
étrangère
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est l'endroit où vous viendriez pour en
savoir plus sur la famille Bell et leur
Esprit sur le mur nous avons des articles liés
aux atomes et surtout ici dans le
coin  nous avons une photo de John Bell Jr
sur certains des documents associés
à sa vie, nous avons au moins un
document ici
euh nous disant ce qu'il avait donné à sa
fille aînée quand elle s'est mariée 110
pour un cheval et une selle 500 dollars pour un
esclave nommé  Mary,
les esclaves bien sûr de la guerre civile
ont été libérées, mais euh, lorsqu'elles sont devenues adultes,
elles valaient probablement entre
douze cents et deux mille dollars.
Nous avons au milieu des trucs
liés à son père et bien sûr le
dessin de sa sœur Betsy
elle semblait même nerveuse à un
âge plus avancé, une de ses arrière-arrière-
petites-filles a déclaré qu'elle
ne dormirait jamais seule, qu'elle avait toujours un
petit-enfant ou quelqu'un avec elle et qu'elle
dormait toujours contre le mur et
laissait l'enfant ou la personne qui l'
accompagnait dormir  l'extérieur du lit
[Musique]
étranger [Musique]
bien avant que le film ne devienne
célèbre, c'était les histoires les
histoires folkloriques chaque fois qu'un livret folklorique
sort ou qu'une nouvelle production sort,
que ce soit un film ou une émission de télévision  les gens
vont s'effondrer en atomes, ils viendront dans le
comté de Robertson pour voir s'ils peuvent faire
partie de l'expérience Bell Witch, beaucoup
d'entre eux sont curieux de savoir si elle
existe réellement et ils erreront dans la
ville et visiteront l'hôtel de ville et trouveront
des directions pour  certains des endroits qui occupent une place
importante dans The Legend et ils
essaieront d'en faire l'expérience par eux-mêmes
J'ai déménagé ici en 1969 et fondamentalement
j'aime le cadre rural d'où je
viens essentiellement et que même si
la région s'est développée, nous essayons de garder notre
règle  cadre et euh vous savez que nous
combattrons la base, je combattrai fondamentalement toute
tentative de la moderniser plus qu'elle ne l'est
bien nous avons une super petite ville
ici et et c'est un peu comme Mayberry
là-bas euh la sensation d'une petite ville et les gens
qui sont à la tête  dans le passé, ils
avaient beaucoup de prévoyance et la façon dont ils
planifiaient les choses et essayaient d'amener les gens
ici et donc maintenant c'est l'un des plus grands
attraits touristiques du comté
[Musique]
vous savez, je pense qu'il y a des choses qui se
sont produites
et je pense que c'est  à un moment donné, quelque chose
s'est produit il y a longtemps qui a provoqué l'
écriture de l'esprit, c'est devenu une légende
et on l'a raconté de plus en plus
et il dit que la légende grandit, elle devient plus
grande et meilleure, vous savez que plus de gens
veulent savoir à ce sujet et  c'est
quelque chose qui s'est produit, mais bien sûr,
c'était il y a si longtemps que nous ne pouvons pas l'expliquer,
des choses étranges se produisent tout le temps dans les atomes,
mais surtout pendant le jeu et la
semaine de l'esprit, les deux derniers week-ends d'
octobre arrivent, vous ne savez jamais ce que
vous pourriez  rencontrez chaque fois que les gens font
l'expérience de la sorcière cloche et qu'ils viennent
ici, ils veulent en faire partie et donc
ils passeront soit par la grotte, soit
par l'école ou le
cimetière et ils peuvent avoir des problèmes de voiture
par la suite, que ce soit ceux  les
problèmes de voiture sont dus à la négligence ou à la
cloche que vous savez être vue, mais
beaucoup d'entre eux aimeraient attribuer
les choses qui leur arrivent et
l'expérience qui leur arrive à cause de la
présence de la cloche dans le comté de Robertson
étrangère
[Musique]